a passenger jet with more than a hundred
people on board has crashed in
Pakistan's southern city of Karachi
authorities said the plane operated by
state-run Pakistani international
airlines was enroute from Lahore the
Airbus a320 came down in a residential
area just moments before it was due to
land now let's bring in oisin Abbas
she's a journalist based in Islamabad
machine apparently the plane crashed
into a residential area what more can
you tell us at the moment we don't have
all the information but according to
preliminary information there are at
least 102 people on board including crew
members and in crashing to a resident
residential area near the airport onto
about seven to eight homes and there is
footage of it that nearby residents have
taken with their phones
this was the flight that was carrying
passengers a home for eat from Lahore to
Karachi which is about a one-hour flight
so it's not a very long flight and
neighbors have reported that there was a
huge explosion and then there was a ball
of fire that engulfed homes and it is a
very densely densely populated area
where the plane crashed yes what we're
seeing live pictures from what appears
to be an area close to the scene what
can you tell us about this residential
area well it is supposed to be a very
densely populated area and at the moment
there has been a state of emergency has
been declared in all crash hospitals
which suggests that there will be mass
casualties at the moment we don't know
the numbers but this is all the
preliminary information that we have
thank you no Sheena bas for this quick
update